as a doctor in the field of pain
management
i work in a world where you bring us
your pain
and we treat it
we ask questions we take the symptoms
you present
we decide what tests to run
we listen with compassion and wisdom
and choose the best course of action
based on our knowledge and experience
combined with science and sometimes in a
very small window of time
as physicians we took a sacred oath to
do no harm and the system has gone a
great length to teach us and set up
guidelines to make sure that we treat
every patient equally
and without judgment
as we stand there in your moment of pain
we run your situation through every
filter we have
to give you
the best care
and for most of us
this is more than just a job
it's a calling
but as we stand there in your moment
looking at your story from all the
different angles
and all the different rational voices in
our head run through the decision-making
process
there's another voice in the mix
and this voice
while it isn't rational
or informed
yet it often dictates our decisions
and we don't give it a second thought
because you see this voice existed long
before we began studying medicine
and so we accept it as truth
and this voice sometimes calls the shots
it's what i refer to as the undiagnosed
bias
and it's causing suffering and death for
many with chronic pain
i have spent the last 15 years studying
pain
its cause its treatment and its
management but it wasn't until i found
myself sitting on the other side of the
exam room
that i noticed the crack
in the foundation of pain management
when i discovered that hidden voice that
exists in all of us
that hidden voice which i termed the
undiagnosed bias is more commonly known
as implicit bias which is a bias that
exists based on our unconscious beliefs
and associations
implicit bias in health care was brought
to light in 2003 when the institute of
medicine published a report titled
unequal treatment
they found that regardless of insurance
and income status racial and ethnic
minorities received worse care
and when it comes to pain research shows
that bias extends beyond minorities to
also include women and even children
dr susan moore was a black female
physician whose story was heard around
the world in 2020
the story of a doctor who struggled to
receive the care she knew she needed
her pain was due to a health issue that
she fully understood and described in
medical lingo to her doctors
yet her pain
was dismissed
when she posted her experience to a
group of thousands of fellow physicians
there was an uproar of support i mean no
one could accept that a doctor would
treat a patient
let alone a fellow colleague like this
simply based on how they look
but that's the problem with implicit
bias
most of the time you are unaware you
even have it
i remember the year i went from doctor
to patient
it started off as a small pain in my
foot that just wouldn't go away
well it grew worse to the point that it
overshadowed my life it was this
constant companion
affecting my work and my family life
i finally went to go see a foot surgeon
and was told
source not clear probably tendons were
inflamed he said
and he prescribed a boot and some
physical therapy
but the pain worsened and it spread to
my hip and my back i sought out more
medical specialists even holistic
practitioners
all with different theories
but no clear diagnosis
or source of pain
i began to feel like i was going to have
to live with this forever
and as the pain kept progressing with no
clear diagnosis i even thought to myself
wait
am i making this up
is my pain even real
in an online survey of 2400 american
women with a variety of chronic pain
conditions
91
felt that the health care system
discriminated against them
and nearly half were told that the pain
was all in their heads
so let's go ahead and dispel that pain
myth right away
if you're worried that your pain is in
your head
you're right
because pain is in everyone's heads
you see pain can't take place without
our brains when you step on a nail for
example you stimulate nociceptors or
specialized nerve cells that send a
message through your spinal cord to your
brain
well your brain then decides what it's
going to do with that signal
if it senses something dangerous it will
process that experience as painful to
prevent you from further injury
and the decision by the brain to process
it as painful is based on environmental
and social cues as well as by culture
and one's past experiences
now contrary to popular belief not all
pain is related to tissue damage
pain is actually defined as an
unpleasant sensory and emotional
experience that can be associated with
actual
or potential tissue damage
you can have real pain
with no physical injury
or source
pain is the one thing that can't be
measured by a monitor or lab test it's
hard to quantify or qualify it's
measured on a scale of 0 to 10 that is
based on one's own perception of what
they're experiencing
pain then
is subjective
and as doctors our process of treating
pain begins with identifying its source
which presents a problem when there is
no source
for when there's no source it becomes
open to interpretation
an interpretation becomes open to that
undiagnosed
bias did you know that the different
sexes experience pain differently
now for the sake of this talk when i say
female versus male i'm referencing sex
assigned at birth and when i say woman
versus man or non-binary then gender
identity is at the core of the point
females have more nerve fibers than men
and there's a hormonal influence to a
variety of chronic pain conditions
at puberty rates of chronic pain rise
faster in girls than boys and as females
approach menopause sex differences in
chronic pain
begin to disappear
females experience more recurrent pain
longer lasting pain and higher overall
levels of chronic pain than men yet the
majority of studies on the treatment of
chronic pain have only been conducted in
men
did you know that women are more likely
than men to be given anti-anxiety
medications instead of painkillers when
they present to the emergency department
complaining of severe abdominal pain
even for extremely urgent conditions
such as chest pain from a heart attack
women experience delays in life-saving
interventions that can prevent death
research shows that clinicians more
often suggest
psychosocial causes such as stress or
family problems to women patients in
pain when they would more often order
lab tests for a male patient with the
exact same symptoms
for black women such as dr moore they
suffer two blows
the insulting notion that they are over
dramatic due to their gender
along with the erroneous view that
because their skin is black
they are impervious to pain
a 2016 study of a group of medical
students found that nearly half believed
black people have thicker skin than
white people
less sensitive nerve endings or that
their blood clots more quickly
the origin of these outrageous claims
dates back to slavery and the 19th
century experiments by dr thomas
hamilton who tortured black slaves to
prove that black skin was deeper than
white skin
and dr james sims a gynecologist
conducted experimental surgeries on
enslaved black women without anesthesia
contributing further to false beliefs
that black women
experience less pain
there were times that i found it ironic
that as an anesthesiologist whose
livelihood is centered around managing
pain
that i would suffer from chronic pain
myself
and so like dr moore i became my own
advocate and dove deep into the root
causes of my own pain
after five years thousands of dollars
and many hours spent in pain i finally
found the cause by diving into
integrative and functional medicine
now my pain was due to physical
imbalances triggered by childbirth
years of stress and sleep deprivation
and a dietary sensitivity that had been
triggering inflammation
over time i healed myself and finally
the pain began to ease
but while my own pain did fade my
passion for other people with chronic
pain
grew stronger
now doctors aren't the enemy
if you ask physicians why they went into
medicine you would hear
to help people
so much so that during disasters and
global pandemics health care workers
kiss their own families goodbye to go
take care of yours
they work tirelessly during codes to
resuscitate your loved ones
and shed tears
when they lose them
but with exhaustion time pressures and
overcrowded emergency rooms comes the
ability for that hidden voice to take
over our rational one
now the health care system has been
teaching bias training
and studies show little to no explicit
bias in health care which is great
but we continue to see implicit bias in
a percentage of health care
practitioners
because it operates in an unintentional
and unconscious manner
implicit bias begins outside the walls
of the hospital
and is brought in
unknowingly
and it's not just doctors
bias exists in all of us we can all do
better
how
well the first step is awareness we need
to begin by identifying our stereotypes
and then rewrite the stories of the
people we meet
when a woman sits down next to us ask
ourselves what would we say if this were
a man
would our answer change
and for those whose pain has been
dismissed fight to be heard
finding the right doctor can feel a
little bit like dating
you may need to swipe through a few to
find the right one for you
but don't give up
and don't delay seeking treatment the
sooner you are properly diagnosed
the greater chance you have of breaking
your pain cycle
as physicians we took an oath at our
white coat ceremonies to first do no
harm
and most of us live by that sacred oath
but part of that vow needs to include
staying in check with that inner voice
to make sure that we aren't writing a
story
that our patients haven't told us yet
because it is our duty as physicians
to replace the undiagnosed bias
with empathy
and
to all of you out there who are
suffering with chronic pain
we hear you
and we're ready
to listen
thank you